this this is it this is the time when
you're gonna when your agents and
managers are going to tell you take down
videos on the ridge yeah this is gonna
be the whole Jewish joke related be sure
that's kinky no I don't even talk about
jewish stuff ever in my stuff I know
it's just been so done I know that's why
I do it cuz it's been so dumb because
it's so over I like to I like to do the
objects so much more to me than one of
my parents religion the whole point of
me ryan right is to capitalize on jokes
that have already been beaten to death
but still think they're funny
hey guys i'm ryan right oh and I'm
Arianna Arianna and I are gonna check
out the trailer for a movie starring
patrick stewart who played Charles
Xavier in the x-men movies it was
Captain Picard on Star Trek thank you
recognize him when you see him and it
stars John here from napoleon dynamite
and a couple of other things that people
don't remember the ice skating one late
glory now is a good one it's called
Christmas Eve that what are you doing
I'm just I just being prepared Christmas
Eve there's Hanukkah for Jewish people I
celebrate Christmas too that's not right
I don't celebrate Hanukkah you know why
cuz I'm not Jewish why do you celebrate
Christmas what are you doing cultural
thing cultural it's a belief in Jesus
thing everyone who celebrates Christmas
believes in Jesus obviously false wow
that's the devil document enough
religious jokes aside people is that
real let's have a kid appropriate
audiences James is a reorganization oh
my god Napoleon Dynamite I got the name
wrong i was thinking of Johnny hater
yeah my bad yeah let's do that again
then it's realize no beginning no
nothing beginning I don't know when you
say let's do that again all right hold
on a second appropriate audiences well
that's like getting James Harris just
three organizations become necessary
which results in the termination of
James Harris I'm doing fired laid off
but it's Christmas Eve very late
our Christmas those that
I always knew I would die and an out I
will find you fire you and then make
sure that you're fired from your next
three jobs after back hello y'all right
now we may just be the last man and
woman on earth why don't you help me get
us both daddy ex-employee shall not
infringe upon the workspace of company
need you to pray for me dear god this
for their feet their dad's gonna kill me
any funds on those five laid off
[ __ ] is this movie there's no such thing
as a question without an answer you
might not know it now but it's out there
waiting to be found I'm going to find it
there's no feeling like it in the wall
Merry Christmas
feel like we saw the whole thing I don't
even know what the [ __ ] that was I get
it I resident Ines de your Valentine's
Day yeah brothers liked story yes I'm
one night yeah I've seen those concepts
before but I don't really care to see
these six thorities they don't look that
interesting to me I get it I'll probably
watch it really I could a lot of movies
you'd watch this I'd watch that with my
parents I don't even get the tone it's
like what could happen when these
unlikely people are put together without
technology this that first it's like
goofy comedy then it's like Oh heartfelt
dramedy then it's like a horror movie at
one point oh now it's about finding each
other wait what comedies yeah I get it I
know but it looks a little bit
pretentious I think this is the kind of
thing I would have liked written like
the concept for I've been like six doors
and elevators I can't you feeling wait
to work with you one day well the jokes
in there didn't land for me what jokes
oh you're not fired you're being laid
off oh that's a joke and I will fire you
in your next three jobs hello hello okay
yeah yeah I get it I get it I'm gonna
watch it look I can let you guys know
how thanks Rory I'm gonna be born on
Christmas Eve if I go watch that you
know we have to do by we I mean Jews go
see movies on Christmas what makes sense
that if Jewish people watch a christmas
movie you're gonna be like oh this is so
exotic and different than my culture I
get it right so I work at all that's not
work it's so exotic about a Christmas
movie you know it'd be exotic if I went
to see a Hanukkah movie this doesn't
make any sense just cuz they don't exist
isn't eight crazy nights like a family
tradition for you guys never even seen
the whole thing wow yeah wow your people
would be excited it no they wouldn't the
basketball on the grandma did Moses lead
the Israelis out of slavery so you could
not watch a crazy night sorry yeah
I'll soften the only thing I want to see
is find out how they're all connected
other than this major blackout in New
York and they're primarily focusing upon
a dynamite impregnated the pregnant girl
okay and he is the son of patrick
stewart yes who is organizing some gala
and has like the instrument people come
in the musician yeah now I don't need to
see the movie there we go you know that
thanks Hollywood thanks Larry King thank
you for your passion project I like that
I'm really and I can touch my movie
Larry King I'm still gonna see it I'm
kidding it might be fantastic who knows
it's just a trailer so I could be called
your I cuz I'm so jealous of people with
Christmas finally some truth comes out
of you anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe today by clicking this
button and become a reject I nuh bodda
button you could follow Ariana's channel
it's a comedy woman female comedian
comedian she proves that women are
actually funny Felsen joke do do the one
where you're like do the one where
you're like oh my parents Danny no not
you the joke about like your parents on
a long okay my parents owned a dry
cleaners so I what ever [ __ ] say what
about Paris Hilton so I'm pretty went to
the Paris Hilton of dry cleaning oh so
no one that's the second part of the
joke you first get them with the Paris
then you get them with to no one see
comedy all the times are just going to
be about my toe saying
Christian colon uh-uh Christian colon to
Christmas movie hey Ryan can I get a
shout-out sure thing man Christian colon
as a Christian should you should always
cleanse your colon yeah it's very
important you gotta [ __ ] out the demons
there's demons in you and that's why you
think cleansing cleansing you you fill
your butt up with maybe what are those
called enigmas an enigma and enemas all
right you put an enema that's where you
take the two because um I've had to when
I was a Christian you put an enema up
your butt and then if you fill it with
holy water every morning I get a priest
to bless me go with holy waters where
Christian colon does and then he
cleanses out his demons which come in
the form of poop I always said [ __ ] was
the Satan's work the devil's work I
don't know what they say do you guys
even believe in the devil you know there
isn't one exorcism movie that's like
Jewish there is i'm looking it up what
is it a spoof we have any Jewish
subscribers not Jewish exorcism in the
possession yeah make sure to check that
out sounds like it's based on true
events yeah I feel like this is yeah the
rabbi's son mm-hmm they got two out of
five stars so there we are joining the
ranks yeah yeah okay areum